[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to a very
special episode of GameSpot live I'm Sam
and joining me today is Cassidy hello
yes my name is chasity today we're gonna
be playing two totally digital games
brought to you by totally digital at the
PlayStation Store that's right we're
playing the swords of ditto and guns of
Icarus Alliance today and we'll be
playing each game for an hour each so
we'll be here until 1:30 p.m. so join us
in the chat we can see you on GameSpot
we can see you on Twitch we can see you
on YouTube so ask us questions and tell
us how to play these games better yeah
if you played it at all we're gonna
start with the swords of ditto so let's
jump into this game we're gonna play a
co-op because we're gonna need all the
help we can get yeah let me tell you a
little bit about this game so the source
video is a compact action RPG and what
we're doing is we're playing co-op as
the swords of dito and we have four days
to explore the island and prepare for a
final battle against more Moe the evil
with evil which more moe alright swords
of dude oh here we go that was again
sorry that's fine there we go so look at
our little guys this is so cute it kind
of reminds me of like a venture time
lumen and Rick and Morty I get I get
like the don't starve I notice for those
of you guys who played on Star it's
super cute but look there's zombies
there's some bugs but we're what we're
trying to do is we have four days to
take on the evil witch and together we
have to do that without dying because
once we die we have to start the loop
all over again but you're get sick keep
our money and I'm sorry that hurt that's
[ __ ] oh yeah this this game is out now
and I'm low on health already I'm gonna
eat some sushi girl that sounds
delicious yeah so you can eat sushi
brought me right back to full health
excellent alright so looking at our map
that's where we were before you see the
circle here we had gotten a map earlier
and telling us where the first toy
dungeon is
you're looking for the toy dungeons
these toys will help you on your quest
to beat more moe so we need them real
bad we also need to level our swords up
by fighting the random enemy is being
counter as you see we're level 2 right
now so we're trying to get up to level 3
before we go into the toy judge
we can't go oh we can't go yeah yeah if
we approach it we might see some more
bad guys but we yet see this is the toy
dungeon and this is where we need to get
into I'm gonna say we can't go in yeah
you gotta fight things yeah and so you
can collect coins by chopping things
eating people up and then you can buy
stickers you can buy food for your
health
let's go - lets go - the map real quick
yeah then let's let's explore a little
bit yeah the town area and then we can
yeah let's go back down yeah we know
that we're gonna have to come back up
here eventually but we don't have we're
not very level yes yes so this is pretty
close to when you first start the game
we haven't done that much we've died a
couple times oh no oh boy but yeah you
can equip things using the d-pad yes and
then it attaches to you triangle yes
yeah this is bad he shot laser beams so
when you die it then changes to a
hundred years later then you have to go
to your old grave and dig up your sword
and start over again and then you become
the new sort of ditto ditto is not the
Pokemon ditto is the town yes and we are
the swords of ditto and as you can tell
right now the town has is cursed it's
not like a evil looking spell on it yeah
because
yes yes you can play single player - aya
opera asked in YouTube but it's so much
harder it's a when you're playing co-op
you can revive your teammate when you
die yes so it's very important here I
want I kind of want one of us to die
just so we can show what the revive
looks like everybody's so cute it's
gonna happen because I've died several
times just while we were practicing um
there are also different difficulty mode
modes yes there are really difficult ok
I need some hold on that milk good for
your bones yes see that's why I love
video games cuz I am lactose intolerant
and I can't drink milk stuff but my
character pen so I are we're not yet no
yeah we go I wanna use making her way
alright I should probably drink my milk
actually oh no it's a brain with it so
we have some type of like poison status
right now alright so we also have this
kazoo that we can use to get to
different areas that have kazoo stops oh
yeah it's like a fast travel right yes I
love that you use a kazoo the fast
travel of this game
all right oh you were answering a
question sorry I was only looking my
stuff for like a second thank you you
aren't answering the question I can just
watch it in back oopsies I'm notorious
for doing that in games cool yeah so
we're in shat on gamespot twitch and
youtube if you wanna say hi but yeah we
only glanced up at it every stuff
because we're both playing here yeah the
coop is it's really fun that's for tri
interaction also I don't know what I
just walked into but I'm excited mm-hmm
someone said you can drink nan like yes
I know I can drink that table but is a
real thing I want cheese hello oh we
can't fight him
he's a sensei about time you showed up
show us the ways sensei teach us okay so
thanks for nothing sensei I thought you
would train us get us all three just
like now you got this like why don't you
help us and say yeah you can eat sushi
too young yes yes you can I have the
sushi equipped to my triangle when I
need it oh the rolling is cute I know I
left a little roll yeah well - all right
it's really useful for dashing away from
those explosive enemies you know all
right let's work our way back maybe
they'll repopulate but we respawn here's
a brain I love destroying people's crops
really hard maybe those were sensei's
crops they could have been yes we are
playing on ps4 because we are playing
thanks to the Playstations worth poli
program yes yes this is the ps2 version
okay they're playing right now now we
have three days so as you see the days
pass pretty quickly and you have four
days total so we need to get to level
three soon and then get our get to the
toy don't you
yeah Playstations spending a lot of
really had been pushing a totally
digital I noticed that you had a totally
digital sale recently and you can get
this game right now you can also get
them to the Chris Alliance and
trailblazers coming random fun fact I
just read this about in their last
quarter they've the 30 percent of all
games bought on PlayStation we're on
this digital store oh wow just so fun
fact check it out it's a toy store let's
see what's inside so we made it to the
town oh look it's a robot friend
hey nerd welcome to the toy shop
toys of legend those sound very useful
I want a okay wait I want to upgrade the
toy because we have these little nerf
guns and I wonder if we can I can no
materials held for the upgrade so check
out some toys yeah we don't have that
much money as you can see but we can get
there's a watch to fast forward time I
don't think I want to do that there's
nothing more satisfying than a big ol
explosion so we can get some bombs what
kind at their bomb and then poison bomb
let's try it let's learn let's buy one
bomb and see how just regular bomb
let's try regular bomb it's do it
alright thanks for the toy bro and
either one of us can probably equip that
so yeah alright let's get out of the toy
store because we're down to three days
wow I don't think I'm about I don't
think the time passes when we're in the
store though yeah I think we're good
like when we're in dungeons when we're
in stores when we're a house I think
time I love this little nerf gun it
really doesn't do anything but you know
you it will become useful later and
we'll show them how but see this is the
kazoo
err kazoo and then we can travel the
first is the no-fuss flying bus that's
cute I love their the the sound of him
talking he reminds me of like Animal
Crossing but with a kazoo sound alright
so shall we make our way back are we
just looking to level up come through
town we could make your way back okay
yeah there we go so I see the blue
square is where we are so we have to
work our way back I'll follow you
yes this game is available now it's
available for $19.99 in the PlayStation
Store app we need to get over to the
next quadrant of the map shall we
alright can you rewind time to well
haven't done that yet haven't tried that
point good question we'll let you know
as we explore I love the art you too all
right so we're gonna win oh yes this
what's in here nobody yeah we don't know
key that key you try to go in this cave
and see what's down here
yeah let's find out what's in the cave
is it minutes in a day is that what you
it's like about eight minutes is what I
read yeah yeah I accra said I don't
think time passes when you're in the
town that's good is it even really fast
other overtopping skulls oh oh hold on
torch dia what do we have towards oh I
do
torch it up that looks like a thing you
can torch can you know trying no I just
broke everything in here Bob Jones asked
can you change your character's
appearance when you die use become a
completely new character yes nothing
like the previous character so it's just
reincarnation
yeah it just changes into a different
character Tommy Tommy no okay there are
an amusing difficult a burger thank you
guys so no you're not changing your
characters trans but by dying you
Brahimi's i oh no i really good but i'm
very low health do you have food no no
sorry that was me i was trying to fast
travel out the dungeon no I didn't mean
it I'm sorry we can do you want to no no
I have a bomb I was just equipping
something because I realized that I had
close to level three so I think it's a
good thing we were in this cave cookies
I'll protect you I'll protect you sorry
I was trying to get a cookie
I had a craving I hope killer sweet see
it guys young Madsen what's this game
about so you're playing in a loop and
you're in the town of ditto oh no
because this is super cute this is super
cute power of love and friendship
provides me that that's the cutest smile
I've ever
it's adorable oh yes so to answer your
question we are the swords of Dido this
is the town of Dido and there's an evil
witch named normo and we need to stop
[ __ ] mo and we only have four days to
do it so we have to do this loot and if
we die we can start over again from the
beginning of the loop as new sorts of do
so you see these things those like fates
mores they like make enemies so you
gotta kill them and then dash away I
just jump to my death
Oh so here's the case or we both die
yes so as we were just mentioning once
you die start from the beginning of the
loop but you do retain I think we still
keep the bomb we just bought yeah the
money that we had mmm so you guys will
see now what it looks like to start from
the beginning we have to go mm-hmm wake
up find our swords and begin again yeah
time to sleep for a hundred years
yeah that's right and loads of the sword
fall to the ground so now we start a
hundred years later and then we're gonna
go dig up our swords from our old dead
bodies I feel bad that the witch has
been you know just cursing this town for
so long so long they're like when will
the sword of dito finally get good that
day may not be today we're gonna try our
best as a front oh best puku is our
guide Beatle Zane chastity earlier I
wish I had a guide beetle to enter your
life same way oh now I look completely
different and I can once we get this to
the story I think I get my options and
journey let's go up yes yes but yeah you
wake up as
a single character it's raining there's
my guide beetle cuckoo for some puzzle
solving heck yeah if you guys are just
joining us we are playing a Swords of
ditto it brought to you by a totally
digital at PlayStation Store that's
right next up we're gonna be playing
guns of Icarus Alliance for the ps4
Groundhog Day he yeah that's right crime
it is I oh my god you're a bird I know
I'm a verb you guys don't know this but
I love birds so my god I know I can't
die as his bird
I might get really emotional you're a
bird I'm a bird you're a bird I don't
like my wallpaper on my phone is a bird
oh I know love me some birds yeah bird
I'm a bird but I'm not a bird all right
we have to go find our swords it's
raining in town
did someone trash his sticker Shack look
at this mess oh not just sticker Shack
someone trashed it alright let's head
this way go to our grave site this is so
cute
dig up our swords and become all mighty
it is a little creepy you got that right
well we're going to a graveyard so go
around this there we go get our swords
and now we are the swords of ditto get
cape say your color changed it did I was
a little bird no I'm not I'm a yellow
bird or brown bird like a rat you're
like a beige beige just beautiful oh oh
my god talking about your cuckoo so full
of yourself poof ooh Wow seven days doc
I says find the whale statue first so
you can start collecting celestial
tokens for every enemy you kill to
rewind time later alright that's a hot
tip let's go back to town town was this
way right yeah okay so the loops not the
same every single time thanks man
location exchange this is not good oh my
god there we go oh you can break out bye
yeah like how we just like sat there for
a moment I was just accepting my fate as
per usual gone into acceptance mode
immediately healed all right so let's
look for some help
let's talk to you the Hall of Records
owner do we already have a circle on the
map
no we owe you oh we do we don't have to
talk to them good great so we can just
go towards that call don't stop in the
toy shop first anything well we still
have the same amount of money so it
would just be the same
bama's Oh check oh never mind you're
right yeah it's all good okay check
let's check real quick
oh wait what's this is there one more
bomb no no they just have added
something else that we can't afford okay
what's back
and back we go I'm gonna go go away I'm
gonna equip something crying said what's
your favorite bird for you some
lovebirds I love birds I'm gonna cook
the chocolate I'm gonna clip a sushi oh
I should have quit stuff too good
thinking I have sushi my favorite type
of birds are parakeets but I had them as
pets and I was growing up so that's why
our buddy Joey who does potato mode has
two birds I know he's got two pigeons
the fancy name is rocket of Joey once
upon time I met Joey I met I met the
pigeons yeah and I met them tell me
about the pigeons so they're they're
really cool they're not that loud
they're actually much quieter than
people think they are and they're very
like they're super docile they let you
hold them they're like pretty chill kind
of bird do you think you are in this
game I will right now I'm a bass bird oh
this is oh I can break out get some
money we need stuff
yeah no no connect so this is where you
would face off against more moe I would
not recommend doing that right off the
bat when you start the game you see more
moans she just steps
yeah he's died with a tentacle monster
yes yeah thing it looks like that it's
very unpleasant
you can use the roll - yes we're level 3
good job we did it
Errol said I didn't know you could own
pigeon touch yeah yes there is a place
in San Francisco called Paloma see where
you can adopt oh is that what we got
pigeons yes Andres go Paloma see all
right I feel like yeah yeah we're in the
direction
oh no there's something blocking our way
check this out ok so we've been lied to
you we judge this sludge in our way so
let's go let's try to go into its castle
I guess no no no oh I guess a donut I
don't it just evaporated did you see
that nothing sadder than a wasted Dona
just in life just in general let's go
this way
and see if we can cut through yes yes
you know all right where is that
entrance
oh oh it's above us go up don't forget
to roll dodge thanks that guy yeah it's
oh here we are a human
Adaline hello she loves my she loves
them Oh dancer rigorous is in the chat
hello hello guns of Icarus beautiful
colors yes they are it is a beautiful
color all right yes actually don't
really help us she just like told us how
much she loved slimy just wanted to make
conversation I think that's fine yeah
ruins stronger than us could you imagine
if you were stuck as an NPC in a game
like forever
yeah like the money is if you're an NPC
in any game which NPC would you want to
be let's go in North I guess oh and a PC
any NPC in the game yeah oh wow they are
locked in right they're difficult for us
we're just gonna have to go through so
let's go to the left and then up and see
if we can get over that way
cuz we've been blocked in by sludge
what's this
let's go down these are the ruins it
just it's just fancy here and if you are
just tuning in you're very confused we
are playing the swords of Dido because
we're playing some games brought to you
by totally digital at PlayStation Store
today
and we'll be playing terms of the price
Alliance right after this at 12:30
good job proud of you didn't do anything
to help let's see we're gonna go up nice
oh no we're locked in I feel like we got
like something we got to do something
no like I had the last time I play a
loop I had to go all the way around in
the most ridiculous way it's a way for
okay so let's go down alright that way
out to the right yeah and then down and
past the graveyard the other way around
okay yeah wait is there can we kazoo you
dry can we kazoo let's dry touch me
you think haha no it's let's just we
incur zu down there but goat yeah just
go down one so we'd have to go all the
way around you do it I can't no there we
go it was me all along
check it out oh that is so cute
oh I said last time we were playing with
elbows
the music's cute it is yes alright so
that was a bit of a shortcut I haven't
much but it helps I imagine the sound
designers for this game getting to play
the kazoo for that I'm being really
excited I would love to get in the vo
booth and just go ham on a kazoo I'll do
that for you
anyone anyone wants honey's money bags
anyone that wants that we're back at the
graveyard how can we get out all right
to the left let's try going left it
around look at that statue what kind of
evil witch erect the statue of herself
in a graveyard
DUP what are you kidding me right up
where let's oh yes I'll try to go into
one of these spooky building oh wait the
all right so so see the question marks
are sludge and we we have in some
trouble here maybe we could try gali
we're gonna try down yeah let's her down
okay let's go south oops sorry dead man
that guy said he would be crazy Earl and
PC Borderlands 2 oh yeah there's some
zombies
ya know no one hurts my friend that's
what I thank you I'm here for you as
always
[Laughter]
oh is that gold or chocolate either way
I'm happy I'm having the chocolate right
now say get some health that is right
alright so where can we go now all right
we can go you want tried to go down we
want to go in the direction of the
circle yeah let's try going but we've
been blocked by sludge so let's go this
way
so they just have a very specific route
paved out for us for us to level up and
get things hot dog Hot Diggity Dog made
out with a hot dog that was one I didn't
actually don't spread that I hope I hope
that they caught that that's gonna be
clip there's gonna be a game spot burn
book and it's gonna have my picture and
dad guy says I would be a crazy Earl NPC
important yes PC what I like I like
those cheering people in the background
I just like to cheer and watch people
play it forever cheer on there's a
little hole in the ground here and I
kind of just want to oh it's not good
Oh watch away oh yeah okay I roll it
very less I got a coffee nice what's in
the hole hey what's in the hole gonna
get me oh I picked up this shrub I'm
having the donut oh yeah and here we go
I'm supposed to do that it could be one
of those so there's these little
dungeons hidden throughout the you can
go down into and write things and put
gold and level up so I think it's okay
there's a ladder just did not expect to
fall is it help oh okay cool so this is
a symbol of the belief in the power of
serendipity yeah I believe in the power
of and serendipity that was a good movie
it was a great movie also serendipity if
you guys don't know it's like a happy
accident yes like it's also great 2003
film star Jim he said yes and Kate
Beckinsale with a great cameo by Eugene
Levy yes as always those eyebrows man
they never quit where are we going
okay alright so this is not good wait to
go back down cuz we're reaching our way
back to sludge let's go over into that
go back down yep yeah I got the sushi
yes never waste sushi
she says this is the correct way
see it's never been late the same every
time you start a new loop yeah that's
cute
can we go in that yeah cron said I want
to be the guy from Street fire to
Russian stage who was drinking yeah like
I was living the life
you must be the sword I presume I'm art
we're both the sword charlie pleased to
meet you
oh what a cute little white house you
have maybe he'll get he's fond he has a
fondness for gossip okay all right well
schmoozing it works Oh
[Music]
I hope he likes the song I sang for him
yes
Errol M said this reminds me of Steven
universe for some reason yeah oh yeah is
it - yes it really does yeah nailed it
alright I'm probably you I swear I think
I know where I'm going
that's me and then there's always sludge
yeah Wow I said yesterday alright we
gotta go up to the right here oh yes
we're on a mission we're gonna get you
Momo so we're going to the toy dungeon
so we can be better equipped to fight
more moe and then there are two anchors
that you should take down in the game as
well and that will help you fight moral
otherwise morale will be super strong so
you're so what you should do is get go
to the toy dungeons we have six days go
to the toy dungeons and then take down
the okay but it's okay because we can go
down this way look I mean I'm patient
it's funny I believe you everything is
fine
bojong's Jesse relaxing today it's
definitely everyday you guys don't know
this but a really good singer we didn't
sing forget about universe video
recently Oh what
no no it was the Hyrule Hyrule's
funniest videos that's what I sang for
all right let's start are you going in
our April Fool's video what's in the
house let's try I'm just really curious
it's a guy hello from do you want to
join us
give us a thing well I mean I'm we're
the ones that walked in house oh okay no
he thought we were enemies we're good
guys okay hi goob goob said hey ladies
are related by side a bunch of cons yeah
I I didn't play it at cons either cuz
I'm usually working but I thought the
art was super cute them glad that I
finally get my hands on this game brains
goals totally um it really doesn't
remind me of Adventure Time now that
someone brought it up okay
we're doing it we're getting so close to
the toy dungeon let me tell you it is
12:01 so we have a half hour left of the
swords of dito before we switch over to
the guns of Icarus Alliance can we walk
on this stuff try it oh yeah oh kawaii f
totally is Boop this game is kawaii
walking on sludge all right yeah that
was our bad crime walk into someone's
house and ask why yeah just walking in
there are other things you're likely no
wonder why it's just nobody ever does
the woman Pokemon I don't know it is a
rude thing though this game is correct
we are yeah their toy dungeon all right
so we found it in our first go-around so
now we finally found it in this garage
and now it's lit up because it's lit
because maybe over love it we are well
equipped to take on the toy dungeon
shall we yes I'm gonna equip a hot dog
but you know just watch out friend
there's a guy like this I do like that
they are kind of slow moving guns of
Icarus said this game is so cute the
switch will be a culture shock
oh no it's me fine I can sing for guns
of Icarus too
[Laughter]
every once in a while I love your songs
okay what's the name of the game this is
the swords of ditto thanks for joining
us Chris Kraft yeah and if you are just
joining us we are playing two new games
brought to you by totally digital at the
PlayStation Store and now we're going to
a toy dungeon so the gist of sort of
ditto is you have a limited amount of
days to take down the witch and you need
to take down some anchors get some toys
in order to do so otherwise she'll be
super-strong and just beat you up
because I'm gonna hook up a hot dog
not something here and yes there is
difficulty modes we are playing the
relaxed mode right now yeah because we
have an hour we play baby play normal
and we have as much more punishing yes
so we just wanted to make sure we were
able to get through enough of the game
augmented by the rules help within this
rule by you can revise the rules on this
dungeon at your convenience pressing
options okay vanilla all toys up
disabled what so we did yeah yeah and
cuz we were broke and it doesn't matter
yes started that all over again
crime says somebody should cut the audio
from this room a couple small they're
not gonna be great yeah an entire album
of my shady songs that I just made up
during the stream would be awesome
alright I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't realize he'd stuff okay get it I
get it
let's go alright how to continue alright
the rule is vanilla that the rule is
Anila nice shoot through the wall
oh oh oh hey what's you three long you
have to shoot the right thing yes nice
so keep those did come in here is that a
torch thing I just always want to lights
there we go
yeah we're getting it look at us in the
toy dungeon solving puzzles ah
alright okay oh jeez I wanna shoot that
I'm gonna there's spikes all around us
oh geez I keep doing the same thing I'm
sorry okay we're doing what am i
shooting coral the blue block up top I
eat all right just do these red ones
purpose you should probably eat a you
know sushi oh I should huh okay
it's sushi we have lots of food because
I yo thinking about alright wait is this
blocking a alright this do we just go
through it should I believe okay alright
can we get through yeah negative we
cannot get through what do we have to do
and probably something oh there's a
switch on the right side okay alright
shoot it again my body burn body
oh alright now we shoot it again go go
up slightly and then shoot directly go
up a little bit more yes
today today on streams have learned
spikes are bad yeah the hard way yeah
maybe that does [ __ ] unlock a door
around here somewhere
good call alright shall we and as our
red barrels girls are always bad barrels
are always bad I mean let's go shooting
them to destroy other enemies alright so
something it looks like there's some
kind of mechanism happening so let's
figure this out alright so what happens
ok so we can't I'll shoot it again oh
there's a platform ok so how about I get
on it and leave actually let's go ok
yeah we shoot so ok and then then we
shoot that one ok I go down here and
shoot at it
no yeah come to me get on the platform
ready okay
we're learning we're learning everything
is fine everything I'm so okay so I just
a really miniature story right now
I was playing punky the other day my
friend and he's in the middle building
him in the North Building and he's in
the South building oh my god this spray
paint I love his smile and Horrell about
him more than stories I blew up my
boyfriend with my own bomb like so I
died and then I threw I throw a grenade
and he went to go save me and I blew a
smoke so I mean I'm just curious for
things like bad games look I did a thing
oh my goodness
oh no oh that was a bad button to press
yeah I shouldn't impress that button
that was not I'm need a hot dog a cat
those are cats a cat throwing a bomb Oh
No
okay let's continue on hold on what what
are we missing
oh it needs to be read for us to pass
shoot it with a shoot it oh my god I'm
not sure you know oh sorry I was trying
to keep hitting that switch trying the
guy hoops let's go around him he killed
Sam I didn't mean to I have the key
thank you get in there get in there you
can equip the key and
see where is it maybe no actually is the
key I need the key
I thought we can I guess that key
doesn't open this huh let's see let's
get our bag okay all right I think it
should just work it's probably it's
probably this lock
oh yeah yeah I think oh we like really
deliberated that for a minute like hold
on torch time okay oh okay and then how
do I get to that I need to forge that
oops
what is this brake hand doing to me no
oh no oh my god I thought we'd I thought
we were gonna die there all right it's
okay does this teleport me where does
the scope what is what happens maybe we
just have to go what does it do how do
we light the torch that's on that
platform you see the other torches how
do we light the light though all right
[Music]
what do we do
sure okay third so there are like unlit
torches when we hit the button we can't
open the store it no when you press the
thing
there's no okay so we need to light
these up how okay how do we get across
there's really the question
oh wait maybe throw me what's my range
you never have each other or a dove
throwing you
I will here pick me up I did okay throw
me don't kill me though throw me that
yeah let's let's see if I'm running I I
can really three maybe I was run towards
it and then throw me yeah just try the
one up top let's try with a platform oh
no no no what the wall try with the wall
until we get the hang of the tossing
yeah alright no like that bad boy there
it is all right here just jump off into
a respawn maybe yeah on that platform we
didn't think this oh wait no we do you
think this through
this is not going well no okay this is
rough this is not happening
all right all right I could Bob jump
says there was a much easier way I'm
dead
we're gonna start oh man we didn't think
about this oh no aah oh oh that's how it
happens okay massage but now I can't I
can't revive you because you're stuck
over there okay at least like the torch
doesn't go on without me okay I don't
want it
so how do I so now I should yeah so we
need those yeah we need that it we
needed to go through the other torches
and light up the unlit torches okay so
you say okay so you need to press the
button and then hit the pan to swish you
see what I mean fire and then switch is
that I'm doing and then switch the time
it so that it lights up so just eat that
bottom one now and then switch
do it again arrow horizontal arrow and
then switch switch okay there we go that
work it worked okay there we go
thanks Bob Jones all right maybe you
will respond I can't have to revive you
away are you kidding me why is that
necessary
just don't go on without me I think I
think we're stuck okay so let me I'll
just kill myself and then we will start
again oh no we didn't think about it we
wouldn't think about these consequences
broken the camp okay
well it's okay hopefully we can just
come back into this area we know we have
to I mean that the circle will be in the
same area but we will have the same
obstacles we're going to get back to you
probably I don't know we'll find out
soon enough
yes we will next episode the swords have
dinner yes and that's what that's you
know it's you as you call to a rogue
light yes you know it's kind of yeah cuz
you still keep some things from the
previous game but you do start over from
beginning so you start over a hundred
years later and you become a completely
different character so now cuckoo wakes
up a new potential sort of did oh you
know I'm sad about I'm not gonna get to
be a bird this time probably never know
you never know this is true way to find
out I'm sorry we broke the game whoa
you're a bunny I'm a bunny okay all
right I mean look these are cute too yes
I mean I'm sorry it's not a bird but at
least you're a bun I'm a bun if you're
just tuning in we're playing the swords
of ditto
brought to you by totally digital at
PlayStation Store we're playing for
another 15 minutes before we switch over
to swords of Icarus Alliance
what we will be playing with some of our
friends from news games but right now
yeah sordid it Oh check it out it's cute
it reminds us a lot of like Adventure
Time although Steven universe the
universe for sure if those of you played
don't starve I was really into that game
for a minute it kind of gives me those
vibes yes
a very cute bun you're a bun it's so
cute and if you're looking to play this
game and do better than we did
it's in the PlayStation Store it's
available now it's 1999 all right we're
getting our sword getting our sword back
some of the buns of Icarus buns of it
Chris buns I guess now we get really
guns of Icarus Alliance sex buns of
ditto bunny too many titles that you
t-bone said have you guys done a review
on swords of dinner yes there is a
written review on site sorry for miss
speaking earlier swords of dido guns of
Icarus you swap what's up flop double P
normal gear oh wait does that mean that
we're switching teams what's the mortal
gear about here further increased ether
elemental resistance we could do
increase ether out we could do this one
increase either a mental attack okay so
stop confusing why this case it said
sorts of different no chastity all
morning Isaac stop now Ridgeway so if we
look on the zoom op that's there's a
circle let's try to work our way back up
but as you can see the path is gonna be
different it's not gonna be the same
path that we did
critical
all right show it
yes I like this time I get little purple
cape and every time I go
that is really I know right bunny makes
amazing sounds hi Jake what's up guys
hello Jake all right okay we're still
level three so we should just go after
and we're out of time I'm gonna put some
stuff though
what thing equiping I don't have much to
do shall we
okay we're going up it's not blocked
right nope I don't think so
we are level four right now
we maintain our level yes no goob we are
not freeing back any of those awful
nicknames you guys made up for me on the
last week oh I was thinking about it I
know oh if you missed the last name that
means Sam did not I can't even be bad
goob is kind enough to bring that up
thank you because my name is impossible
to make a good nickname for yeah either
half of my name is not a good nickname
for oh man don't I'm not gonna alright
let's check for that toy damn now that
we know what's up I think we might
actually be able to go through it oh
wait there before are we for yeah yeah
we are no way are we I think I thought
okay you know we're not no they make you
work for it
ssam B this is super cute I'm quite
enjoying it I do love a good co-op yeah
me too
it's so rare to have a good patch co-op
game you know everything that's what
multiplayer these days is online oh oh
sludge see we got sludge doubt okay so
let's go down this way then probably
let's see or can we go what's up right
up top left I mean yeah that's right
all right making her way
making her way checking them out real
quick yep yeah okay
thank you this brain just licked me
that's nice
sorry it's okay okay are we love it
yes okay honey
I knew that would happen
we just need to get some love before
hello who are you
what's your story Oh Oscar yeah we'll
try we've been trying but they've been
asking us for hundreds of years okay so
we about eight minutes left at the sort
of ditto before we switch to guns of
Icarus Alliance I'm glad I know that I
can break out a bit yeah hi cyborg man
this game what is its name this is the
swords of Judah thanks for tuning in we
are playing the swords of did oh thanks
to totally digital I PlayStation Store
and then we're going to switch over to
guns of Icarus Alliance
let's go down I can't like threw you
over
I mean I thought it was a good idea we
both thought it was a good idea this is
no one's fault but both of us we didn't
ask what the obvious like the thing that
was happening and what you know like
those arrows at the fire yeah that would
have been like the most obvious thing to
ask like what is that about
Marian here I'm sorry
there's the toy dungeon we still need to
be level 4 or to get in there
yeah see we locked out there's some
enemies
this is a good spot because and we can
actually just continue to farm here
because see there's a little thing over
there that's spawning we should have
just stuck around
all right up to the toy dungeon we go
MLG gaming hello hello to you as well
alright now we can get in the toy
dungeon or halo halo if you know to me
and get it so it's funny I value you
here I'm here all day it's fine as if I
don't do the been for too long
yeah in my review of Avengers infinity
war I said it really is a marvel that
they were able to order that way what's
the secret code the secret word is
element 0 ok I almost have no effect
alright now what oh I put it in here
yes ah
Errol's and I just thought yesterday I'm
gonna sue me me an Avengers infinity war
well I hope you enjoyed it actually
okay and then I would do this way what's
in this pot was I not supposed to do
that cuz the only way we can go in here
nice this is cool so the dungeons change
every time and let's fight let's fight
this SOI boy I have a bomb yeah think
let's see yeah let me try coping it I
should equip stuff oh I don't have a
bomb I have milk now let's see what
happened just a milk okay oh no what are
you doing my friend I can't trust you
even though your door open you squeak
it's cute
alright so that door opens should we
just keep going yeah let's just take it
as it is and be like yes there okay
okay how long does this last alright
alright okay we got some platforms good
let's go I'll go this way
you're way ahead of me all right uh how
do we open we don't have a key so let's
go there was another door find a key
there was another door open if we go
back mm-hmm Wow look at you
Rollie pollie sorry is it in here now
nuts and so there is another door that
opens below us here so it's just like
skip this guy is well thank you there's
got to be a key in here this seems like
a key like room so here's a situation we
have another you know and then we have
this all right I'm gonna oh wait could
you come yes you meet and go in there
yes I like that up Wow he does not look
friendly cool so we did that now we need
is there another arrow thing to light
that up or nah you see that whole step
on this button oh okay for children
oops it Daniel okay so we still need to
like mystery teachers there but there's
no arrows like there were in the last
dungeon so you attack this I yeah
can you help us are you a friend no he
makes enemies not a friend confirmed
great ok is this after supper is this a
situation where I have to throw you no
no no no wait no cuz I'm not gonna be
able to get off there remember yeah
move this room is getting awful though
mm-hm
I think this is where we end the stream
CBA unless each runs a platform can you
trick him he's a baby oh okay does
anyone know how to light that torch
tough break huh you can smack that block
you can smack oh hey all right you know
what I think we've does that I could is
this is this what we yeah we're at 12:29
yeah the rats are gonna all right so in
a perfect world we would have gotten
through the toy dungeon yeah it takes a
while but you can play swords of did oh
um by going to the PlayStation Store I'm
getting it for $19.99 play with a friend
play by yourself
we're gonna play guns of Icarus Alliance
can you switch over to us and then talk
a little bit about this game while I
sign in and talk to my friends yes I
will let you guys know a little bit
about guns of Icarus Alliance it's a so
the description is on the skies and a
steam-powered airship that's of Icarus
Alliance the team based online game that
pits co-op crews against both rival
teams and AI that learns your tactics
players become part of the story as each
battle shapes history and ever-changing
steampunk world developed by muse games
we're going to be playing it on ps4 and
it's available right now for $14.99 yeah
and we are gonna be playing with some of
our friends at Muse games one of them
was in the chat so I hope they can hear
me and they're gonna send
invite and I'm gonna join but we're
gonna have four matches today if you
want to tell them the different game
modes that we are planked and yes so the
very first game mode we are gonna be
playing is PvE 2ve it's called Search
and Destroy and it's gonna be hard to
the lobby right now the map is gonna be
on drowning waste if you guys know or
familiar with the game and our ship is
the pyramidion the position on ship will
be engineer on top deck I am so excited
for this game by the way I have two mics
right now cuz one's not enough for me
and also I just need my teammates to
hear me yeah yes did you sign in already
with I am signing in right now so I
think guns of Icarus is and the twitch
chat and they're gonna send me an invite
and then I can join them we're gonna be
hanging out yeah for a minute
actually so you guys should see this yes
because I can they can hear it but
despite our prosperity we desire
and I'll greet became village yes check
this out for a little bit raged said yes
he looks like light of our achievements
famous T so we can discern from the
darkness awareness the disciplined
countries of the Asia Empire the Geisha
impose the Anglian Republic Marauders of
the frozen ruins the proud desert
warriors of the Arashi league cool the
Vigilant Order of Canada guardians of
the natural world
I love steampunk
Bob Jones also said really liking the
intro now yes boss throats of a new age
we must once again choose our destiny
guns of Icarus said we would love her to
be able talk to us yes that's why I have
double mics and I will be able to talk
to you I'll be presence or talk to you
guys
yes are you gonna be switching headsets
so that you can I like to this one or
I'll be able to hear them in games oh
cool ahead and switch back to us and
then I'm gonna join them okay
I love a good game intro like that but I
was a kid I used to those were like the
moments where I would get really excited
for a new game that game intro
yes so we're gonna play
[Music]
and joining the match yes I'm in alright
alright hello yes so there's not gonna
be a delay I can hear you I can hear you
in the game so we'll be able to talk
just fine and yes this game is all about
communication and teamwork
I agree cool so we are in then yes if
you are just tuning in we are playing
guns of Icarus Alliance and worth
playing this thanks to totally digital
at PlayStation Store and you'll be
hearing some voices joining us today
and they will be the voices of our
friends from Muse games who develop this
game we have Howard Matthew and Wendy on
our team then we also have the community
manager Miko who is gonna be our
co-pilot know if you know this but in my
Twitter bio mm-hmm actually all my bio
so it says I flew here on an airship
mm-hmm with Syd it's a it's a Final
Fantasy reference but morale story is
that I really love airships I think
they're really cool
so I'm quite excited to watch you play
and maybe hopefully get a chance to play
this game
yes I'm gonna give you a chance to play
as well all right so we're gonna play
search and destroy if you can check this
out see that's me and you can change
your presets
just a little bit so I can hear them
better yeah the thing is I'm gonna turn
the game audio but the whole game is
just get a lot louder but hopefully
they're low my ship hello everyone okay
so you take Hey
[Music]
so they can hear you on our stream hi
guys thanks for joining us if you go
into if you go on options can you lower
the music line so we're placing to
pre-match planning now right turning on
my shift
I'll have K so take the main deck as a
pair of midian two guns facing forward
at the top deck cool which I'll have
B'Elanna and avocado on and then okay so
be my main deck engineer a big stuff
don't let us die okay no pressure
yourself alright so as you can see here
there's my engineer this is my gunner
outfit this is my pilot like the
engineer and Howard is actually going to
communicate with attack in a special
attacks all the available for pilot
awesome lots of yeah let's do it
I'm very excited cool let's do it
so yes this if you're just tuning in
we're playing guns of Icarus Alliance
and this is Search and Destroy so what
can you guys tell us about Search and
Destroy it's our take on wave-based
survival there five waves total for each
wave there's a different objective and
we just basically need to meet that
objective and it can be destroying enemy
ships
it could be blowing up a enemy outpost
or it could be taking on a boss so we
just need to be able to do that within
and about a lot of time then we can move
on to the next objective so there's five
total so basically the two ships are
working together to try to you know look
at the badging and take all the
different objectives so it's really all
us working together everybody's working
on the same side okay cool
come on there's a fire on it
I'm playing as an engineer yeah we're
coming in ears
Oh fire oh no I will do else I'll say
over here the order
yeah we took it down look at that team
good yeah
so the way fire fire
so the way I positioned the guns I mean
essentially all the guns in the game are
specialized they can be specialized to
do different things so like some gun kid
knocking up balloons which would come to
the ship's is sink and fall so they kind
of crash sub guns are good Amy add
components like targeting engine so to
you know make the ship disabled and not
move was swor and you can target guns
you can ship the shield on the ship and
make it do permanent damage so the guns
are all designed to do different things
and the way I set it up on this ship is
that I have a Gatling gun the top right
that is great to just strip down the
shield yeah she older ship and then
another a complimentary gun on the top
of the Left called a quarter that's
basically flops like these motor shots
and the way that you can get it killed
quickly the - yeah by the Gatling like
that ship the armor and then follow up
with the border yes
asked to work to get up and tuck that to
make sure that I communicate with Aaron
stone and you get finishing shots in
yeah the guns all designed to type so
the guns all designed to - you know -
would be of course - I don't know I
think they can't hear me but chassis can
you ask them a little bit about the
bosses and
right now we tickety's yeah
[Music]
so Sam had a question about the enemy's
going into the throat of the story and
the enemy is yes he wants to know about
the story and the enemies
so there's a six factions they're all
vying for control of the land so right
now we are in person area strike two
this mission fighting so for those of
you watching who can't hear what he's
saying I'm a little out there there are
six factions and essentially the story
goes that the there you know the great
Wars there's a alternate issue in the
Great War he really never stops at the
war the people fought to the brink of
extinction and from the ruins people
rediscover steam technology and
essentially eventually took to the skies
with airships uh-huh and so and then out
of that you know six fashion rose to
and so the faction shifts I give the
enemy ships I'll get all represent
different rations and there's six
notches
and Yuri concoction
so we can encounter different classes of
enemies they can be you know battle us
close close range they could a snipe us
from long range in the PBE they're also
Plains father's fighters that can be
bought ships
which is this so there's actually a
variety ships are fighting against right
now ooh
mercantile girls like muses Blazers
[Music]
big [ __ ] minute just leave basically
because you begin say and it's really
more like a few against the Horde type
of gameplay so we actually designed we
basically added a special thing class so
that's really every member of the crew
can have a opportunity at a given moment
to be heroic that's cool
and of course of course this
[Music]
pbht
kinda decided to stay in its
people get variable we've got like
basically a lot of food that people say
if we just the major got by 50 meters
that is very cool
that's really cool
oh this is gonna this guy's waiting you
got Rebecca it's got bad boy there we go
nice
yes I'm really enjoying playing as the
engineer so I can help and fix things
and then shoot at the same times I could
still be a gunner it's really cool
I could've been whoa rammed it and we
survived
if you guys are tuning in right now
we're playing guns there's a line I
could actually jump off the help gonna
turn down the audio on our might side a
little bit to tell them what's up I just
updated the information we're gonna we
are currently playing the next our guns
by Chris Alliance with museums and
developers and this is a stream brought
to you by totally digital PlayStation
Store voices you're hearing on the game
are the members of news games on my
t-shirt yes so I'm gonna turn them back
up so you guys can hear them talk a
little bit more about what's the game
and the development specific areas on
the ship specific guns on my ship so
that whether someone's a gutter or an
engineer they're actually you know Wow
well what's the red so it's oh yeah it's
it's actually a gas
a fire oh there's a boss
get up final wave right now I just have
to take out this boss the boss
particular weak points
[Laughter]
wow this is cool so many explosions
today yeah I they can't hear me but I
was gonna say I bet this gets really
crazy in PvP it sure does
you're playing yesterday Wow
also what oh this place [ __ ] oh yeah we
had it called escape pod
all right so you're on the borders here
switch right now to the cattle again yes
the Gatling gun is somewhat fun maybe
for difficulties so you don't go to
reloading this is fun
I love all the explosion
I'm just loving on those pages wow what
is happening
I missed good effort good are you trying
to drive were you trying to drive into
it yes yes yes great job everybody
oh wait there's a high-five actually
yeah that was awesome that was so much
fun oh you got I got a trophy competent
engineer that's me not great but
competent which is most important those
stats I was all over those fires
anywhere but now putting out fires like
you do in your real life that's right
but that fire is just like in real life
except not actual fires I bet I bet um
yeah so this game is super fun I'm
really enjoying it what are we doing
next
so we're gonna play another game mode
next is that correct assault all right
tell us about that
I mean so mean difficulty normal and the
map is Paris Glenn our ship is the storm
breaker and then we're gonna have a
bunch of guns that's cool so my position
on the ship will be I'm an engineer with
a focus on shooting all the cool guns
can do and we have to prevent us from
dying five times I think we can I
believe in us and if you're just joining
us we're playing guns of Icarus alliance
with our friends from Muse games who
developed the game Bob Johnson moon
chess he likes to see the world laser
alright and if you guys want to join in
on the fun is available now so I'll
switch with I'll search him at because
you know I'm not a rashi player so
alright yeah so so I think so I'll
switch out and you know I'll fix stuff
and he can fly this one bigger sounds
good to me
so this I'm not trying to make the
comparison but it does give me mild sea
miles home faction in the sky in the sky
in the sky in the sky it's really cool
everybody gets different roles that they
have to play somebody has to drive the
ship you got a half man the guns you
gotta make sure everything's working I
like this it's like there's a lot of
project management involved and I'm into
that because that's what I do
yeah yeah let's do it all right now
we're doing assault
this is guns of Icarus Alliance
here we go Sam would you like to play
the next round you are doing me this one
or you wanna play the next one I'll do
the next one okay I'm coming in on the
next one
Sam's gonna play the next one after this
I'm gonna play a salt and then she's
gonna join you where do you want me
captain
where should I be head down on the big
watch a friend left the big light hey
what oh this is so check check out this
gun oh my god so I take the Tesla gun
and the whole correct so it's their map
right there
so this game basically find that find
enemy outposts and bases and destroy
them if you do that we win and the lives
of the matches shared so if you fall off
the ship it's just like respawn yeah
that's cool I just respond it's fine
and we ship behind this everything
balance
that why are you loading
Oh
yes
I had a good teacher
okay we're at the first place there's a
weak point on the left shine take it out
all right shooting
yeah yeah did I do it
there's another weekly point over there
fire fire
where is it worth it okay I'm gonna to
crush you I'm on the Gatling
reloading
so I guess you can damage ships by
driving into them as well
nice
nice shot it Out's got it
oh boy guns are blazing guns a-blazing
literally shooting the APUs we're a team
allies
reloading
it's cool that it continues reload even
after you leave it I got it yes wait
where lasers lasers this done you hold
sugar to your charge huh
and let go device yeah yeah and you can
uh so if you could aim at a plate right
you have to scatter so they would hit
the primary you got it at the pole to
scatter actually so like you'd be having
a certain place you can hit the ball so
I should scatter it like
how's the chat to examine
shot is doing good you guys have any
questions let us know we are currently
on a call with Muse gams who've
developed developed this game guns of
Icarus Alliance so if you guys have any
questions for them let us know and we
can ask them so you guys are playing on
PC is that correct
yeah I don't notice at all
Wow so the game is completely
cross-platform on PC Mac and Linux love
the teacher leader so puppy you gotta
that voice is Wendy she's awesome she's
taught me a lot about this game
I'm having so much fun yes shooting
ships out in Spanish this is so
satisfying especially on a Friday yeah
long work week I'm having the best
Friday
yeah post reloading
yeah
do another laser ground triangle you can
see where the bosses
I'm showing them now
Oh God go teammate
Oh
going towards another base
yep
we're just gonna try and outrun this
boss we can do it
cool I get hit by a mine they're the
base spew out of hair box
I live in the second section we're gonna
try and take out the third
I love hitting things with the mallet
yes
if you guys are just tuning in we were
playing guns of Icarus Alliance we're
playing right now with muse games and
this is available right now on totally
digital at PlayStation Store and we're
gonna be chilling here playing for
another 30 minutes I'm going to jump
into a PvP game with them after chastity
is done it were taking up space right
now if gets of anything right now
victory oh it feels so good man we are
killing it today guys yeah really proud
more mad all right I'm just gonna join
you
am I ready for PvP you buy it okay
Sam's gonna join you now so I'm gonna
have her hop on and play with you okay
[Music]
hey guys I'm gonna give Sam a chance to
play yeah just put this around your neck
and then when you want to talk to them
press square and they will hear you in
the game square here yeah so just hold
down square whenever you want them to
hear you so yes we are playing guns of
Icarus Alliance Sam's gonna give a shot
at PvP we just did a salt and we crushed
it it was great
but yeah if you are just tuning in we're
playing two games by a totally digital
at PlayStation Store the first game we
played in the first hour if you missed
it was the swords of ditto you can catch
that later when we put the rest of this
stream back up on YouTube and now we are
playing this or wait not swords we're
playing the guns of Icarus Alliance and
we're playing until 1:30 with the devs
from Muse games and we're hangout in the
chat so if you've got any guys just let
us know what's up can you hear me I
don't know if they can hear me or not oh
I pressed it yeah they invited you oh
I'm just go over there and hit camera
yep hello everybody we're just gonna
join a private match so we're putting in
a code that's right there but yeah we
are playing guns of Icarus lines and you
can play this right now too if you want
to just go to the PlayStation Store it's
$14.99 and yeah we're playing four
different modes today so what we first
played what you just saw was Search and
Destroy and then we played assault mmm
can you guys alright
we are back in the game I changed the
volume settings a little bit so that
their voice chats were higher is it
amber so feel free to ask them questions
normally I fly this ship and people
laugh at me but this map is good for it
or is it funny if you if there's another
ship you say your piece down and I will
switch but I'm flying my ship so I need
to know why people laugh at you and you
find a ship oh because a because I tend
to lose a lot and I tend to be like
really reckless the aggressive and with
this ship because this ship it's like a
kind of a weapons platform it has a lot
of guns facing forward but it's also
really fragile so I tend to get shot
into pieces a lot of times but I have a
feeling that the results would be
different today yes good we adjusted the
audio thank you Sam for doing that I am
going to try my best the role for you
will be easy okay so there are there are
two there are three decks on the ship
actually the middle deck has two guns
and they're both yours and really all I
need you to do is get on those guns and
fire okay cool I might say that I hate
that speed gun the big gun in the middle
has a really long reload
so when dad is reloading there's a gun
to the left of it and you can basically
just hop on there
keep shooting I hear I see here it says
AI crude rayna's engineer am I supposed
to go in and say oh okay cool I'm in
there I'm in there never mind wait were
you in the right one I would hope so
tell them that there was two AI with you
if you if that's a guy's there were two
AI with me is that correct
sorry that was that was a small bug I
just saw that I'm stream okay
okay yeah looked like your old Lobby but
you ended up in the new lab sweet all
right I'm so we're in together all as
well
yes you can see them oh thank god Sam
you could do this you'll repair things
okay I'm gonna go repair things that's
already good that one's already good
don't need to repair that
oh she repaired that already that's your
lying gun oh yeah so when that's
reloading you can switch to the other
gun okay so we aren't going like so we
like our opponent I'm following my
teammate we've got the enemy ship marked
at those like two ships on the enemy
okay so angle you can see the ships use
the cloud cover - the red ones are bad
so those red guys are the bad ships or
dots or dice yeah so yeah we see that
enemy ship straight ahead we'll get in
there get in the gun
oh boy okay so hold your fire for now go
to use this good to know
mountainous cover so there is an element
of surprise here to like ambush a group
of ships is a good thing oh absolutely
okay so what we'll focus on will focus
on the ships in it especially this map
because there's a lot of a lot of cloud
cover so and it's there's a lot there
multiple paths you can take to engage
the enemy so yeah positioning is really
important so currently we're using this
pillar is covered yes okay so I'm gonna
charge for it so we can create a quick
to d1 so we'll focus on the welcome to
chip yeah super that one straight ahead
shoot shoot shoot shoot because you're a
guy could also disable so it's actually
great to to fire it Wendy can you jump
down and get my engine okay
again okay awesome so what you're
looking at here is a PvP mat the game
mode is deathmatch the map is Canyon
ambush so lock and load is a friend
right that's or is that an enemy should
I be turning that ship with the red
arrow to my die so it was actually okay
super geek out of the ship but you know
oh okay that's what anyone does one of
you don't where's the other ship okay
okay we get there watch out firing the
middle gun yes yes yes yes okay get on
the flak get a flack on it left side in
the middle yes
Oh MOOCs are as close cut a little close
there good job so you take it down Thank
You chasity I support you oh we support
each other so weird in spite of their
mind I was gonna say we're gonna hold
this position but already spotted so
what about this what about this ship
flying excess
[Music]
Macari see you later Bobby Carly needs
to walk dogs on my teammate have fun
with the dogs without us
that's not good Oh No oh boy so we're
still chat trying to take down this guy
oh ship right yeah yeah so I'm actually
going to see if I can join oh we are
being shot up yeah where are we getting
some from okay
it's funny back it's like it's off the
ship guys sorry let's focus on uh let's
focus on lock and load
so in this game there are over 31
different guns there's 13 different
ships over a hundred pay combinations of
ships yes and there's always four beats
on one crew so went up a loon gets
knocked out will actually crash should
we target welcome to goya yes next
target
nice nice Oh was that arts that was our
teammate yeah and we are a long way from
home spawn so well we'll try to we tried
to deal with this ship and see if we can
take it down
Oh got a fixed gun is there friendly
fire in this game generally no yeah
generally no but only with mines so
there is a type of gun called the air
mine so you can basically drop their
minds if you use the air mines they are
they don't distinguish infrared info I'm
not sure which one here so they also
have a game-mode for PvP and air mine is
highly effective in that oh my god but
it just just cost a lot of really behind
us so we are going to regroup with our
teammates so this time because we push
really far into enemy territory and it
gives eventually it gave the enemy and
an advantage in regrouping so we're
actually going to try to be closer to
our own home spawns this time so we try
to hold a line all right
super bad [ __ ] coming to us comeback
time
oh very even so on top that for now
sure perspective
go into the I might
the degasing gun is a sort of health
strip so are the top keep the opponent's
defense okay good so good
the enemy is charging it now so we'll
create a quick to me one right here
there we go
[Applause]
she adds the backup thing
I'm shooting it oh no he disappeared
behind a rock and this is PvP in guns of
Icarus Alliance going
brought to you by totally digital at
PlayStation Store and we're hanging out
in the chat oh no we're not surrounded
I'm shooting this ship I don't even know
what's called welcome to boy yeah okay
well we got it we got it okay we're all
tied up
oops I don't know if I just shot a ship
that was friendly or not okay it will
have the hit marker I love you she got a
fiendish then it won't so a lot of times
if you don't if you're not sure just
shoot
shooting a lot shooting on lock and load
yes so we definitely have a advantage
right now except that a hit
we also shoot at place there are
multiple things that you shoot at but
yeah the main ones are the enemy ships
and there's also other bases funny I
fell off the ship at the exact same time
stop admitting that you guys fell off
ship okay just just lie to me also in
the assault mode we were also shooting
at enemy bases so we were taking down
bases Oh God thank you guys tell them
that we have about 12 minutes left in
the stream and ask them what they like
to do hey guys we yeah we have 12
minutes left so it's that enough for one
more game yeah cool cool all right
looking forward to it you got it you got
this yeah Sam's got this
oops hits him with the itchy trigger
finger defend the team I just want to
defend III keep when I pop out of the
gun I keep using the hammer before I hit
circle I'm really I'm really enjoying
this game it's really fun I love games
like this like I like games like this in
all forms I don't know if you guys if
you guys ever played lovers in a
dangerous space-time it's like it's a 2d
version co-op survival in space on
should cool awesome for play another
deathmatch guys are we playing another
deathmatch
so this will be the last match of our
stream
we've been playing guns of Icarus I love
squid what fun is squid okay oh yes I
would love to fly this I know you do you
guys all have favorite chips yes that's
really fun so this this ship is like a
really agile and really fast flanking
ship it's just a really fragile but it's
actually really great for like circling
the you know bigger more lumbering ships
somebody in our chat just said calamari
crew you're like burning calamari could
you ask them to introduce themselves
late in the stream and say what their
names and what they do yeah
guys do you think you could introduce
yourselves just for our stream who's
been watching and listening for a while
I love that title thank you I'm I'm
Howard I guess I'm more the team lead
producer guy but I've known to take out
the trash nice thank you guys thanks for
playing with us today that's been really
fun
so we're wrapping up with our final
deathmatch of the stream but we've been
having a lot of fun do you like being an
engineer I do I'm really enjoying the
engineer well quite a lot it's fun
because you get to like fix things but
also shoot things I like to be able to
do everything yeah so it's like a lot of
times if you're playing like a support
type role in the team you don't get to
actually shoot things yeah you know so
it's kind of fun that you get to do both
yes get a girl to do both you got
carpets I know I like on this ship has
carpets it's pretty pretty cool yeah you
could have basically to create the ship
so he's actually using a cap that
actually have a do also she can you put
themes on all the ships I think it's
incredibly unsafe I could slip at any
time the railing isn't perfect so it
can't even hold onto the siding on a
super fast super light ship our goal is
to get in fast and get out fast and do
some damage in the okay where do you
want me captain oh we gonna shot it I'm
really digging this map it's like it's a
cave city that's what I was afraid of
are you guys on to switch sides to the
other side with a gun I think I'm a
follow me I'll jump you to the gun
fire on the Strangelove thank you no no
actually how I give you oh boy
am i doing the right thing I am it's one
snack I'm scared oh man I forgot to
bring a extinguisher
oops said digging the desolate
industrial map yeah yeah missing wheel
is it
I'm repairing the Gatling gun on the
front
Bob Jones asked if there's any mandatory
safety designs required for the ships oh
no no oh no my guys broken again
is there another gun you can top off
yeah there's one on the other side man
oh no the other ones broken also that's
all the guns are broken
try the mallet now I got to say gun up
so I'm 525
I'm a trainer we go yes front us back
off next all right hop on that one on
this side there's no enemy I don't think
nope the other side I'm writing to the
other side strangely Strangelove as an
enemy yes basically all the bracketed
ships are enemies thank you thank you
yes so the bracket is spotty which you
have to actively do because you can high
if you lose line aside say for example
if the enemy hiding he's hiding behind a
building or like in a cloud then they
can actually not be discovered they
would lose their spotting so stealth is
a component it's gonna break again
trying to fix the Gatling gun on the
side yeah oh man
oh no we sent ya I got it I got it
life on us this crap short life shot out
fixing the gun you'd like lift us with
their shooting watch it I think we're
gonna extend the stream by a couple of
minutes just so we can see a low an hour
of this are we gonna repopulate okay
cool so we're gonna respawn now great so
then we are gonna extend this bringing
Micromax okay well just to finish up
this map
yeah this is close to the end of our
stream we are playing guns of Icarus
Alliance on ps4 but we're gonna cross
platform with a broken four friends at
Muse games who are playing on from on it
reloading oh my goodness shooting him
hello Eric green yeah good job
no a vine I take I take it back see I
achieve in late this is all about
airship on airship combat it's up to
four players man and each vessel can
take on the role of a pilot gunner and
engineer steering the ship due to air
gunning down opponents repairing a
ship's battle damage the ships are
customizable as you see we put up on a
bunch of rugs on this one let's seek
reloading reloading quick moving charger
or a massive dreadnought and there's six
oh you got RAM to death so three right
now yeah so we're down to kill
don't worry Kazi cause he said I missed
everything
we we are gonna put those on archive
version of this stream up on YouTube yes
over the fact yes yes it will be yeah
so you can see a whole hour of us
playing through swords of dito and then
a whole hour of us playing guns the
Vickers lines to the other gun yep
oh [ __ ] oh my god I'm gonna alright
though on my way gonna come back if I
was like oh no I'm repairing the gun
exceed it wait am i fixing it yeah I am
yeah yeah you see the color changing on
the side there we go back in business
they can jump back in
didn't do that at all no you're good
it's doing it so that's the best I can
do with the tools that I'm given firing
trees left
Wendy's our engineer running around the
ship fixing stuff yeah what happened to
you one right now
reloading but it's also out of range for
me a little bit
oh no just kidding I'm back in
yes yes reloading oh he's a Titan I sit
down to the sky because I want to reload
there we go
welcome to Goa get it a little bit less
take it out well
by a little bit nice excellent hide for
for the last one I did not fall let's go
in with confidence it's meeting the
battleground this is it I'm excited guys
this is it this is fun this is like
pretty intense right now oh yeah spot it
Strangelove yeah psycho flank inflective
get missile there we go
Erik said make them pay for breaking
your gun break their guns that's true
you could shoot it sways reloading uh
almost suck get their guns
oh no random just gonna shoot this out
so it reloads
guns hoping to chop-chop oh no I
shouldn't hear strange look at the job I
know I'm a little out of range I'm dead
eh oh yeah they're young Oh Wendy kitty
boy if they passed me by five five five
I'm sure - angel oh yeah let's engage
Strangelove - get it off our team its
backers yeah my teammates going down any
other oh did we thank them thank you
guys so much for playing with us sitting
on stream thank you guys so much and it
was some fun somebody in chats that all
we needed was Wendy's cheering to get
the win
so thank you guys fun and it was cool
getting to play with you all we're gonna
actually wrap the stream up now so yeah
thank you for ending and helping us out
on a high note
thanks - thank you bye guys and thank
you guys for watching and yeah you can
check out these games right now in the
PlayStation Store the sorts of Judo and
guns of Icarus Alliance are both
available there once $14.99 once $19.99
and thank you Sam for almost thing with
me and playing these games
I thank you shasta for hosting me
playing these games it was super fun and
thank you guys everybody for watching
good games
you